well there's been another night of
arrests in Israeli raids across the
occupied West Bank too let's now speak
to our correspondent Nita Ibrahim who
joins us from rala Nita we were talking
earlier we understand there has been
also the death of a prisoner in Israeli
custody what more do we
know we know that Omar a 58-year-old who
has been arrested in uh on October the
9th has been in a good health condition
according to his lawyer who just spoke
to him during his court uh trial case
via video conference and then a few
hours later he was declared dead by the
prison Service as you can imagine people
here are saying that the Israeli prison
service is taking Revenge from those
prisoners basically subjecting them to
violence as well as torture leading to
the death of the prisoners so these are
all families uh of people who have been
detained by the Israeli forces some of
them just in the past two weeks because
we've been seeing the numbers of those
detained by Israeli forces increase and
people have been sharing their
testimonies of these Israeli arrests and
the raids and how it was very very
violent but the most important thing for
these people here is that they need to
know what's happening with their sons
and they
can't Nita
Ibrahim Nita Before I Let You Go I did
want to ask you we know that arrests
have been escalating Israel says these
are members of Hamas including some
fairly prominent ones I
[Music]
understand Anastasia can you repeat the
question I'm having a trouble hearing
you oh sure I I was just asking you um
we've been hearing from Israel that the
arrests are of Hamas members including
some some pretty prominent leaders is
that your
understanding our understanding is that
some of those arrested are affiliated or
have been in the past affiliated with
Hamas but there are people who have been
arrested who are just workers from
inside the besieged Gaza Strip who used
to have military permits to work inside
Israel those people as well have been
arrested there are very conflicting
reports about their numbers remember
people here usually approach NOS talk to
them about the status of the prisoners
but after the escalation they haven't
been able to get much information so
they don't know what's happening with
them Nita Ibraham there with the latest
us from rala in the occupied West Bank
thanks Nita